[Música]
[Aplausos]
79.1 millones de mexicanos tenemos
acceso a internet eso representa el 67
por ciento de la población nacional es
una bendición somos uno de los países
más conectados a nivel mundial
apuesto que no lo sabía en mi andar por
el mundo en muchas asociaciones
relacionadas con tecnologías de
información y aprendido a eso y más pero
también he aprendido la cantidad de
riesgos a los que estamos sujetos
gracias a esas bondades de la tecnología
nada es gratis definitivamente no es
tener la tecnología y supone un riesgo
cada vez mayor pero bueno vamos a hacer
un pequeño ejercicio regresemos el
tiempo muchos de los que están aquí
seguramente tienen videograbada la boda
en nuestros formatos vhf beta sino la
boda el bautizo yo personalmente tengo
mi fiesta de 15 años
y la graduación de la universidad la
tenemos en bh
hubo quienes hubo otros yo todavía no ya
no alcancé tuvieron la precaución de
hacer la transferencia de sus datos para
poder tener esas imágenes valiosísimas
disponibles
y es entonces donde nos damos cuenta que
perdimos mucha información porque sus
recuerdos se fueron esas memorias se
fueron
pero algunos por ahí están películas de
8 milímetros y demás ahí están todavía
permanecen y podríamos recuperarlas hoy
día la mayoría tenemos
una cosita de estas en las manos
o dos o tres dependiendo de estas
cositas nos han llevado a estar super
conectados quién necesita una libreta de
direcciones hoy día nadie quién necesita
un mapa impreso nadie
quién necesita ir a una ventanilla de un
banco para hacer operaciones muy pocos
hacia allá vamos
pero entonces
tenemos que ir trabajando en cómo vamos
a poder continuar con nuestra operación
en caso de que esto nos falle les voy a
platicar en el mes de mayo de este mismo
año tuve la oportunidad de ir a una de
las reuniones de una de estas granjas
asociaciones donde soy miembro del borde
de directores asociaciones de tecnología
dicen que en casa de herrero hasta donde
palo me ocurrió
subo al avión
seco la batería no tenía más que el 40%
me quedaban 5 horas de vuelo dije qué
voy a hacer si tengo ahí todo el
entretenimiento la música la lectura los
correos bueno
el pequeño detalle los datos del hotel
el vuelo a quien debía llamar para que
pasaran por el aeropuerto y me llevarán
al hotel etcétera etcétera etcétera
evidentemente puse a funcionar mi plan
de contingencia poner en modo ahorro de
energía mis células y si fue tan modo
ahorro energía que se fue por completo
en negro no encuentre nada
cuando estaba en el avión todo iba bien
cuando bajó del avión cuando no tenía
que buscar a quien llamar no lo encontré
lamentablemente fue una noche medio
complicada era una de la mañana en un
aeropuerto en el extranjero otro idioma
pero afortunadamente tenía mi plan b que
fue la impresión de toda la información
la mayoría de nosotros no tenemos esa
información impresa no tenemos un
respaldo de lo que tenemos aquí que diga
yo quien si deber de verdad ha hecho un
respaldo de su celular o de su
información importante en la última
semana
bueno me preocupa el resto llegando a
casa por favor váyase en un respaldo de
eso se trata
amén de la clase de ciberdelitos a los
que estamos expuestos de verdad yo
después de esta experiencia al bajar del
avión y darme cuenta que el teléfono no
encendía me di cuenta que yo me saque
solita no necesité que nadie viniera a
hackear me hay muchos allá afuera que
nos van a hacer muchísimo daño pero si
se los permitimos si les concedemos ese
poder acuerdo pues nosotros somos ese
primer hackers es el primer hacker
cuando no tenemos la precaución de
cuidar nuestra información de saber
dónde la vamos a colocar a quién se lo
vamos a dar a quién no
fue entonces cuando también después de
reconocer que me jaque a solita y que lo
podría seguir haciendo porque la
tecnología va a ser parte de mi vida
cada vez más fue cuando decidí que tenía
que poner en marcha y no sólo para mí
digo lo mejor es quedarme lo yo pero eso
no está bien es compartirlo con ustedes
y es aquí donde les quiero compartir mis
5 puntos para ser ciber resiliente
personal si ya hablamos de ciber
resiliencia pero hablemos de lo personal
porque ahorita primero somos nosotros y
los nuestros número uno tenemos que
proteger nuestra información sin lugar a
dudas
proteger nuestra información es decir no
andar entregando nuestra información a
cualquiera navegar en sitios seguros
muchos de los que estamos aquí viajamos
constantemente y por equis y o siete
veces los datos pues son un poquito
caros en los otros países y qué haces
pides la contraseña de la wifi pública
este primer error ponemos ahí
comprometemos todos todos nuestros datos
esa es una necesitamos cuidar cómo
tratamos esa información y navegar a
través de lugares y portales seguros o
si no de plano pues no navegamos tanto y
tengamos un plan de punto número 2
respalda tu información
si respaldamos llegar lo había comentado
ya sea en un disco duro externo en casa
en tu computadora pero que esa
computadora también por favor las
respalde en la nube porque lo físico
estos aparatitos no tienen ley sí y esto
que acabo de hacer sé que ya me pone en
riesgo
el rato saliendo de aquí voy a tomar
agua y seguramente tengo que dejar que
fluya y a la hora que pasa de eso
sientes y escuchas y ese terrible sonido
que nadie quiere escuchar no es la que
cayó el celular al agua
si por ahí rieron algunos son los que ya
les pasó
y los que no se rieron y saben que les
puede pasar o no lo quieren admitir a
todos nos puede pasar respalden lo
cuiden lo de verdad ese es el punto
número 2
punto número 3
[Música]
plan b necesitamos tener siempre una
fuente alterna tanto de verificación de
la información que nos están dando
pero también una fuente un fondo fuente
alterna de donde dejé los datos
por favor digan yo quien recuerda más de
5 números telefónicos vigentes
perfecto no son muchos estamos hablando
de menos de un 20% de esta sala
cómo llegar a un domicilio
perfecto ciudades nuevas ya no y ni
siquiera nos preocupamos por buscar el
mapa impreso verdad ya pasó hace dos
semanas en buenos aires
pero sin embargo yo sabía que no iba a
tener datos en esa ciudad de manera
inmediata fui por mi máquina impresa
entonces necesitamos una fuente alterna
de acuerdo hablábamos de la navegación
segura pero también de sitios seguros
pues nada más de adónde nos conectamos
sino de qué sitios tenemos en los
últimos años el ciberdelito se ha
incrementado
méxico es uno de los es el cuarto país
más atacado en todos los niveles
empresas personas y demás y seguir
haciéndolo en tanto no pongamos medidas
medidas fuertes medidas para nosotros
medidas para nuestros niños educar
esa navegación segura no es nada más
entra a través de un portal seguro es
educarnos educarnos y saber identificar
y discernir cuándo es un sitio seguro y
cuando no es un sitio seguro
es complicado pudiera ser pero no lo es
a veces es una es una cuestión de
sentido común no por ser los primeros en
aplicar o twittear o pasar toda la
información no verificamos la fuente hay
muchos que conocemos que de pronto ya
está salió que vuelva la mosca y es el
primero que lo que comparte y ya después
sabemos que se estaban robando los datos
descubre a qué artista te pareces y le
dan click y quieren ver si todos porque
todos los que le pusieron se parecían a
brad pitt obvio no pero bueno quién
fuiste en tu vida anterior
y qué te importa la anterior no podemos
todavía descifrar lo que somos en esta
imagínate qué nos va a importar lo que
está allá atrás
la última la última algo así como una
licencia de manejar que ha salido esta
semana nombre
tu profesión eres lo que atrevida
necesitabas que una máquina te lo dijera
digo si no lo sabes seguramente alguien
en tu casa de tus amigos de lo ha dicho
no entonces ojo por ahí y por último y
aquí lo tengo
back to the basics
se acuerdan
como le llamamos esto en la escuela al
acordeón
efectivamente muchas veces depender
tanto de la tecnología
nos hace olvidarnos
de la escritura de ver como escribimos
de ver qué dicen cómo lo hacemos dónde
lo ponemos y nos retenemos
hay muchísimo muchísimo más que hacer
todavía por la tecnólogo por 'born por
las personas por la ciudadanía para
hacer ciber cyber resilientes puesto son
apenas cinco acciones que podemos echar
a andar para poder continuar vigentes y
ciber resilientes a nivel personal
compartan la información
[Aplausos]
[Música]